hey everybody and welcome back to
parkitect
today it's time to tackle jungle
adventure which description states
deep in the south american jungle you
are tasked with building a thriving
theme park
a state-of-the-art inverting wooden
coaster provides a useful starting point
but due to the lens extremely remote
location
attracting guests will be difficult and
then we have a bunch of calls blah blah
blah
obviously i'm going to complete this
using no blueprints
but completing everything before june
year three might be
a little bit of a challenge anyway we'll
see the main thing we have to achieve is
build five coasters with an excitement
rating of 65 or above
so that feels fairly doable let's take a
look
at what we start out with so we already
have one coaster
so that realistically makes the goal to
build four coasters
and as you can see this coaster is
already occupying a huge part of the map
so really we're gonna somehow have to
worm our new layouts into this existing
very difficult to work with terrain and
around these layouts as well
now this is a really huge coaster i
better actually give a
quick pov of this thing uh before i
start building
so this is another one of those terrain
conforming woodies
this one was very much inspired by wood
coaster in
night valley in china which is
absolutely one of the most
amazing looking wooden coasters in the
world although
unlike wood coaster this is actually a
gravity group
timberliner coaster and unlike wood
coaster this one actually has inversions
as well
so so far it's just a typical wooden
experience
small station flyby actually no that's a
transfer track flyby
we get back into this section at the
start of the layout
and then into a huge corkscrew over here
so you know it doesn't do too many
inversions just one section where
it does these two corkscrews but you
know it's it's still pretty
unique experience and a huge sprawling
layout
so something uh that makes this scenario
certainly unique
and as for the land we get to work with
it's all very
terraforming heavy very hilly and very
foresty too so we're gonna have to clear
a lot of this out
and to see where we can fit in some new
layouts i also think we might have to do
a little bit of research because we only
start out with the floorless coaster
flying coaster and wing coaster
lots of b m's actually let's quickly
turn on
research for coasters and yeah let's get
started
so before i explain what i'm doing in
this clip let me go ahead and remind you
that
these videos of mine are all time lapses
they are sped up parts of video that are
very
carefully curated out of my experience
of playing video games
and edited together to appear as if
they're all one single smooth recording
all of these things are very misleading
and
i often get told that i play these games
very fast or
i'm really good at deciding what to do
and and what kind of things to build and
things like that
this couldn't be further from the truth
these videos aren't just
sped up they're also cut and sometimes i
leave out bits or
i edit together different segments from
different days sometimes it takes me
weeks to finish a single scenario
all that to say is that i'm actually
nowhere as good as it seems sometimes
and i spent
a lot of time at the start of this
scenario just spinning around the map
trying to figure out where the heck i
could ever build a coaster
because usually and i guess this is a
little bit of an advantage for me
usually i like to design scenario maps
so that you always have certain spaces
where you can start out building rides
you know this is something that i
noticed a lot of roller coasters tycoon
scenarios did
whether consciously or subconsciously
is especially near starting areas of
parks or just places that you could very
easily start building you'd always have
some easier time navigating to terrain
and then once you get to the end of the
scenario ideally
that's when you have to try and start
fitting things in and working out how to
maximize the the last available spaces
of the map
this map however i have no idea where i
was originally thinking coasters could
even go because this map is
really difficult in terms of terrain
there's trees everywhere which make it a
bit more
difficult to figure out where exactly
the terrain is going
and most of the somewhat suitable
terrain that is there is already taken
by the wooden coaster so
trying to figure out where you could
possibly build some coaster layouts
realistically at least is very tough on
this map
and one thing that also kind of struck
me is that there are no obvious places
to put stations
i guess there's some nice flat land
around the entrance area to put stations
but there's nowhere obvious for lift
hills or anything like that to go
so eventually i ended up deciding to put
a station
across the valley from the wooden
coaster station and build a launching
coaster
now with the different coasters that are
available at the start of this scenario
there there really wasn't too much of a
choice here if i wanted to do
anything remotely realistic so i figured
my best
choice in this situation is to go with
the bmw coaster
and build a launch twin coaster kind of
like the one
in holiday park thunderbird which is
such a cool looking coast i wish one day
i could write that thing
um it's it's definitely on my far to-do
bucket list as a coaster enthusiast
but for a european like me not the most
easy place to get to
but you know one day it's uh it's
definitely a goal seems like one of the
coolest b
m coasters if not coasters in general
especially because it's really rare for
b m's to feature lift hill
but to get back on topic in this this
scenario
i thought it would be a nice way to not
have to deal with the lift hill fitting
in somewhere and make a very
lengthy straight out and back kind of
layout with a wing coaster
because a traditional kind of realistic
wing coaster layout was definitely not
going to work out on this map i was
toying around with the idea in my head
of having a
drop like a usual wing coaster like say
phoenix in toverland
where you just do a inline twist into a
half loop but i feel like a dive drop
just wouldn't really work well on this
map so it ended up being the
launched wing coaster now all this time
i was kind of planning
to leave some space available so that
somehow
i could move another b m coaster into
the space and see if there was
just enough holes between the layouts of
the wooden coaster
and the path and where the terrain is at
to to put some elements through there
and see if i could build a florist
coaster so that's uh
my next plan here and i chose a very
strange setup for the station as you
might see
and i started doing this actually for um
space reasons i have this very large
flat space of land which
which has paths above it and also the
wooden coaster so there's
not really much i can do with the height
there but it would be strange to have a
really long
station and also i had to uh navigate a
curve around the corkscrew that the
wooden coaster does there
so the way to do both of those things i
thought was to have
an entrance station and an exit station
just separate loading and unloading
platforms like many realistic coasters
so in a sense it's it's almost kind of a
nice
touch as well because it it's something
that real life coasters do very often to
increase capacity it's something that
you'll
definitely see very often at disney
parks or things like that
maybe not so much on b m coasters but it
is something you could do
um so in that sense it works out but of
course my main challenge here was
trying to fit a coaster station into
this space
another thing that this this makes it a
lot easier for me in a sense is
somehow i had to get the entrance queue
and the exit path back to the to the
height of the path that's above there
which is three tiles above where the
coaster station is
that's quite a lot of high to make up
and then i also had to fit a queue in
somewhere
so having these two separate loading and
unloading stations
allowed me to actually have different
paths going back up to the top
i have no idea how i could ever fit
both an entrance and an exit with their
perspective with their respective parts
uh in into the space of a single station
here so
in in all kinds of space related matters
i felt like it was a good choice to have
two separate stations
and then when it comes to the layout i'm
honestly just doing some stuff that
works out with the very limited amount
of space that i had i was a little bit
inspired by daemon
in tifa league gardens in copenhagen
to do a kind of compact curvy drop
before we go into the vertical loop so
we end up doing some meandering before
we go into the first inversion on this
coaster
after that we have some more curves into
a sidewinder underneath
the lift hill through the corkscrew and
we kind of get some interlocking
corkscrew action with the wooden coaster
there
i really kind of like that interaction
and then after that corkscrew we go into
a long tunnel
pause by the unloading station it's kind
of straight there but it has a little
bit of a bunny hop as you might be able
to tell sometimes when i tilt the camera
and then we go into the the letters
section of the layout where it actually
does something very similar to the
florida's coaster we have
two cobra raw esque inversions
although the florida's coaster has a
proper cobra raw and the wing coaster
has a kind of
diagonal cobra roll that changes
direction which is
i don't know if that has a name i don't
know if it deserves a separate element
name but it definitely
seems like something fun to do like a
very nice way to make a
135 or 90 degree curve i think
anyway after this i had to move into the
into the theming department of the
scenario which is
honestly one of the most fun times i've
had theming
in this game in a while it's it's not
because i really like the theme
but because i created this really big
mess for myself that i had to clean up
somehow with all of these paths and
coasters
intersecting each other more often than
terran intersects itself
there was a a lot of space that i had to
fill with buildings
uh to try and make it all look a little
bit less chaotic
and hide some of the messy stuff going
on below there
and it's also just something that forces
you into playing with heights
a lot more and i think it's it's always
nice to have these scenarios where
you're forced
to think about things like this because
especially myself i noticed that when
i'm not challenged uh in this regard
when i'm just given a flat map
and flat rise everywhere at the same
height i
just really start admitting to the the
easy location
and start building very predictive
themed lands that don't do as much
interaction between paths and coasters
whereas if you have an area like this
and you've already got so many different
elements intersecting
it automatically just makes the scenery
a lot more interesting for me
because you have all of these different
layers that you're playing on
paths on different heights coasters
intersecting all of it it creates really
interesting interactions between the
people on the rides and
watching the rides it's the kind of
thing that reminds me a lot of fantasia
land and maybe that's why i like it
it's uh it's simultaneously a little bit
of a weakness because sometimes
it means that you're gonna have to
sacrifice some layouts
like in this case these layouts would
not be you know might go to
b m coaster layouts they they are a
little bit weird in places
but all of that interaction more than
makes up for it and i think
this kind of goes for fantasia land as
well terran has a layout that on a flat
flat piece of land would make no sense
uh it's far from the best
layout you could theoretically make with
an intimate blitz coaster
but because it's in the super compact
location because it has all this
interaction with paths and scenery
and because you know the challenges that
fantasia land has with
the really difficult terrain in the park
it just makes the ride so much cooler to
be an and to watch it go around and
that's the kind of thing that uh
eventually ended up coming through in
the scenario and
i feel like if it weren't for the
ridiculous terrain and the wooden
coaster that you start out with that
kind of just
goes through everything you could
possibly plan yourself to try and keep
rides
uh nicely separated from each other if
it weren't for that
i would have never played the scenario
the way that i did
now i i've talked a lot about the
general setup of these coasters in the
area but i haven't even
talked about the theme and to be honest
i never
really knew what to do with this theme
my head canon for
the scenario as you start out with is of
course it's somewhere in the jungle
and my idea was that it could be
in south america something like peru
or along those areas of course you have
the adventure theme
so you could really do some south
american temples and stuff like that
or you could take it the more
contemporary approach
and build a kind of colonial
architecture with spanish influences
i feel like all of that kind of stuff
works out but in this case
i decided to throw away all of my
references to real world architecture
and just see whatever i could come up
with with the adventure theme
and actually one of my bigger
inspirations in this case
is some of the architecture in horizon
zero dawn the game by guerrilla games
uh some people might be aware of this
game some people might not
but it's a game that i haven't played
but it's a game that i have seen
and it looks really cool and there are
some really awesome pictures
of some of the builds in that and that
was really what i took some inspiration
for him uh for this build but not that
much i don't think you could
look at this and look at horizon zero
dawn and like point out
certain types of structures or anything
that are based on it
but it was that kind of jungle-esque
fantasy scenery that made me realize i
might as well just go very fantasy on
this build and see what i can come up
with
with
all of the pieces in the adventure pack
and stuff that we've had for a longer
time
and i feel like the one thing which i'm
most happy with
is this kind of art deco influence using
the
basalt rocks which are usually of course
reserved for
volcanic rock but in this case i figured
they actually make really nice pillars
they go very well with the textures in
the adventure pack
and allow you to add some vertical
elements to some things which
works out really cool for the buildings
but especially that bigger tower
in the middle which i end up liking so
much i'm gonna make
some sort of sibling to it sometime soon
but yeah it's this
weird eclectic mix of pieces and and
making it all look a little bit
overrun by vegetation so you can see i'm
putting all kinds of ferns and vines
everywhere on the buildings
uh that was my uh my main goal for this
whole
scenario and then over here of course we
get
a very big catwalk for the wing coaster
honestly i wasn't sure if it was too
necessary you don't
necessarily need a catwalk like this uh
with the uh
for the lim section i suppose but i i
thought it just looked nice
and the same goes for the the lift hill
of the b
m coaster eventually as well but yeah
once the main buildings are in place
the only thing i still had to do was try
and fill in all of those spaces between
where you
have the paths going from building to
building or you might have some areas
that you want to cover up
or some areas that could use a little
bit more stone
at the end of the day a lot of this was
just trying to fly around the map
to see how things looked and just keep
adding stuff until i was happy with it
this was very unplanned it's all very
organic
and kind of random in places same goes
for this toilet building i was
looking at this and thinking i need
another piece of scenery but i don't
think i quite have the space
or the need for a food court here i
might as well make the fanciest toilets
that i've made on my scenario play
through so far i think
uh and once again we start off with that
two by two vertical base although in
this case
i'm using some of the round walls in the
adventure pack to add another floor to
that and we just
gradually start tapering it off to a
higher point
and this this really just kind of
reminds me of two things art deco on the
one hand which does this a lot with
vertical elements
think of buildings like the empire state
building for instance with the chrysler
building which
aren't strictly art deco but it's that
kind of inspiration anyway
but also fantasy towers
fantasy towns with crazy spires and
things like that like to do this a lot
as well just a lot of verticality
which is really nice and then we top it
off with a custom spire
which is still too much fun to do and
with every new dlc that the game gets
there are just a few more pieces that
you can use
to throw into the mix to create some
slightly different looking things so
in this case i've decided to throw some
pyramid tops from the adventure pack in
there for some
added bonus texture along with uh lots
of
straight and 45 degree angle pyramids
and all together they make a pretty
interesting kind of complex
looking triangular shape to top off the
building which
you know this is a fantasy style so we
can do whatever we want
um i thought it worked out also
interesting to note is that the color
scheme
for this entire themed land is just a
color scheme that you get
as you open up the scenario so we have
the kind of
blueish color kind of bluish green
turquoise-esque
we have red and a very dark almost
a little bit orangey yellow which are
really nice
tropical colors i think a light purple
also goes really well with these colors
but that's something i haven't tried in
this case but yeah
basically that color scheme that you
start off uh the map with
on a few buildings and some pavilions
is just what i'm gonna keep throughout
this entire scenario because i feel like
it works just
too well to not keep using it anyway
that's it for now let's check back and
see how the park is doing and hopefully
we are turning enough of a profit so
that we can expand and build a few more
coasters
[Music]
alright let's pretend that that didn't
happen just now
honestly i just forgot to record a real
time segment here and
after i picked this file up again a few
days after the original recording
i started recording time lapse again and
overwrote the save file that i had
so yeah this is uh this is where we
ended up i'm just gonna add an extra
long segment at the end where we go
through all the coasters and take an
in-depth look at the scenery because i
i do like to have those real-time
segments in the middle of these videos
originally when i came up with this
architect series which
at this point is like two years ago i
think
the very idea was that i would try to
blend real time segments
with time-lapse a little bit more
eventually i ended up
focusing still mostly on the time lapse
sections because otherwise these videos
would be getting
way too long and i do want to finish a
single scenario
in each video or else this series as a
whole would become way too long
so yeah just for efficiency's sake this
is mostly time lapse but i do like to
have those real-time segments
here and there just so you get an idea
of what i'm building while i'm still
building things and to try and get the
best
out of both genres if you will
where especially looking at things in a
real-time segment you
get some time to zoom in on certain
scenery details and of course
follow the coasters as they're doing
their layouts and kind of see what's
going into all of this work
anyway let's continue with our next
coaster and
as far as i remember this is definitely
by far the hardest layout to build
mostly because i was just running out of
space and
i wanted to try and see if i could have
this coaster interact with all the other
coasters that were built so far
so that means we start off with a
station on the higher section
of this map we get a terrain conforming
lift hill
it's it's almost a little bit tatsu i
think because this is a b m flyer
and i'm really trying to use the terrain
to my advantage of course and after that
lift till we take some elements
kind of swinging from side to side on
the hillside and then finally
we dip down over this lake once again
and doing another cobra roll
now i was thinking about this cobra wall
for a really long time because
b m flying coasters in real life don't
have cobra raws
at least there isn't one so far
most of these tend to have very typical
elements mostly the pretzel loop which
is really the signature b
m flying coaster element or light to fly
elements as they call them which are
basically half
in line twists or barrel rolls and also
they like to add
some kind of vertical loop or dive loops
and things like this but none of them
feature a cobra rule
and i was thinking about this figuring
you know there's no reason why a flying
coaster shouldn't have a cobra rule and
i think especially if you're starting
the cobra roll
in an inverted position it would
actually be a really cool
and like disorienting element
i actually think the banana roll would
be even better on a flying coaster
and obviously it doesn't exist so i
don't have
a real life reference for this but i
have been on a banana roll on takabisha
and it's a really disorienting element
maybe because you're not used to it but
especially because it kind of curves you
in in ways that you're not
used to while you're also hanging upside
down 45 degrees it's a really
bizarre experience and i feel like that
could work really well for a flying
coaster
anyway for this one i'm sticking with
the cobra roll which isn't quite as
disorienting but i think for a flying
coaster would be pretty cool
and in this layout after we hit the
cobra roll we
get into a second lift hill because i
had to make it over this hill sometime
and you know i figured i might as well
put a pretzel loop in this layout
it's a signature element of the b m
flying coaster and i have a perfect
space for it here
so we end with a section that's a little
bit shorter than the first section but
we do have a pretzel roll in there
and uh we go into an inline twist after
that
i mean i guess it's a zero g roll but
it's it's very
flat so you know i should probably call
it a zero g roll but
i don't think it's even really hitting
zero g's there's probably still a half a
g or something with
how gentle that hill is but yeah that's
uh that's basically the layout
after that we have one very tight curve
at the end that comes back into the
brake run
and it just does that thing which i
really love when you manage to to get it
to work with
coasters and that is it hits the final
brakes with very little speed
so it's a nice and efficient ride that
has two very short lift hills
but also huge elements and a top speed
of 90 kilometers an hour so that's
when you know you're using the terrain
to your advantage to make a layout
that you would otherwise never be able
to make
now as for the the theming on this ride
i'm going to stick with the same kind of
scenery for this entire map
and for this place here i thought it'd
be nice to do another kind of tower
build but keep this one a little bit
lower
i was thinking that it would be
interesting to have a kind of
hidden away station somewhere in the
middle of the jungle that's not too
obvious
it's not a big weenie or anything you
know get the w
word out there as well um but it's just
this kind of hidden
temple complex somewhere tucked away and
i think it also creates a really cool
vibe
when you go as a guest to the the
entrance area here and you walk through
the queue you've got the interaction
with the coaster
the zero g roll flying over itself and
actually being kind of a station flyby
as well and then just all of these
buildings around you it's very crammed
kind of claustrophobic but i think it
works out pretty well
especially because it's really its own
standalone thing i'm not placing any
other rides or buildings or anything
else in this area
this is just the flying coaster area
it's also not the most realistic station
area
and i realize i am always very
inconsistent with my realism in these
playthroughs because sometimes
i feature some transfer track areas and
sometimes i don't
sometimes i feature a realistic block
section at the end of a layout and
sometimes if i really can't work it into
the layout
i don't do that either for this coaster
it's not
as much of a realistic station because
the the helix at the end just worked
too well into this existing station
building to add a separate transfer
track or
storage shed or anything like that at
the end there's hardly even a proper
block break section at the end the only
thing that makes this coaster work as
well as it does
at least in terms of in-game capacity
and throughput
is the fact that it has two lift hills
and the second left hill is
vaguely somewhere in the middle of the
layout and as far as efficiency goes
that is basically the perfect scenario
because you can dispatch coasters
as fast as you can without having to
have a second train wait
on the final block break section or
anything like that
instead if they've cleared the second
lift hill you're good to go and you can
keep trains moving
at all times so as far as block breaks
so
as far as block breaks go and block
sections having two lift hills on a
coaster is definitely a throughput
advantage and i think this is also why
coasters at disney especially
big thunder mountain like to have
multiple lift hills as well it's a nice
way to add in extra block bricks
without having to you know make it too
obvious
that that's what you're doing anyway
moving on to the final coaster of the
scenario and this is going to be the
final coaster because it is number five
ladies and gentlemen so i'm gonna have
to
get to an excitement rating of 6.5 at
minimum but given the fact that this is
a euro fighter
it's probably not going to be too
difficult especially if we add a nice
layout with some scenery interaction
some intense elements some inversions
and a themed station
then you pretty much always are
guaranteed to hit the 6.5 excitement
that said this is maybe going to be
the first ever terrain conforming euro
fighter
i was considering eurofighters for a
while in this map but i felt like it's
not
usually the best coaster to use to make
use of terrain with because they use
vertical lift hills
which means that you can't you know do
the thing which terrain coasters like to
do and build a lift hill up to terrain
and then use that same terrain to go
back down again but then i realized that
i might as well build a vertical lift
hill at the edge of
a hill here and try to make the first
drop so smooth
that you kind of gradually go into a
valley and see what the layout can do
after that point
so that's what i ended up doing you can
see that vertical lift hill really built
on top of the hillside and then once you
go down you go down a lot more
than the station height is then we hit a
huge vertical loop
which goes around the flying coaster it
did take a little bit of a puzzle to try
and fit that in
and after that we have some meandering
curvy elements
and finally a barrel roll to end the
layout which
this is a very short layout it's
definitely not the best in the park
i just couldn't fit more into the space
without it becoming very unrealistic
and kind of over the top so i decided to
keep it minimalistic here
but at least we do start with a vertical
loop after the
after the vertical drop which is very
typical for gerstlauer hero fighters
and we end with a barrel roll which is
another one of those cursed lower
quirks that they like to do either start
the layout or end the layout with a
barrel roll which is usually an element
that's
pretty good still when you take it with
low speed or
even better when it's very slow so
all in all even though this is a short
layout i still think it's
realistic enough there are also some
euro fighters in real life
with layouts of very similar length to
this one
so i think it makes sense anyway
my favorite part of this uh this whole
scenario personally
is this structure right here which is
the vertical drop
tower um which sounds like the name for
the flat ride but no it's
it's a scenery piece here one thing
which i've always loved
about coasters with vertical drops and
vertical lift hills is that they're so
cool to theme and especially in real
life you can you can see some fun
examples of this
i think hansa park in germany is by far
the best example they've got two
gerslower coasters with a vertical lift
hill
and two towers that really make use of
the theming aspect of it
for novgorod which is a completely dark
enclosed
lift hill that drops you into a kind of
indoor section of the ride
and then you've got cannon which has a
huge indoor lift here on a tower that's
over 60 meters tall and drops you into a
twisting drop
down that same tower absolutely awesome
so
that's kind of where my inspiration came
from for this tower
the only difference is that those two
towers actually keep the
the coaster train indoors whereas in
this case
i figured the tower would just look too
chunky and weird
if uh if we kept the guests in there not
to mention this is parchitects
and we're looking at this park from an
isometric perspective so it would be a
bit boring to not be able to see the
cars go up the tower
and especially down it so i'm keeping
the track outside but trying to
see how i can work it into the structure
so you can see some wooden beams poking
out there
to try and connect the track to the
tower itself and then the tower
i think is also kind of noteworthy is uh
not using any wall pieces uh really
using no pieces that are on the grid
whatsoever
because with the way that these vertical
towers work in the game is they're two
tiles wide
so if you want to get your tower right
in the middle
of uh where the the the coaster track is
you kind of have to build it off grid so
this whole tower is basically on a on a
half grid
just to be able to keep the coaster
track in the middle so i couldn't use
any building pieces so it's all
cubes and rock pieces honestly
not at all the pieces that are meant for
building this kind of structure
but if you put enough of them together
in the right context with the right
color
it works out pretty well and that's the
that's the thing i always love about
parchitect
there's this really really cool uh
geyser build
that astrotron is doing right now i'll
leave a link
to that in the description the last
couple of days i see he's been live
streaming it and it's been one of my
favorite
architect builds i've ever seen he's
he's done this for a while but
uh especially right now he's going
really far with this technique
uh what he's doing is using the round
cylinder pieces
that you get with those basic pieces in
the game giving them the the color of
rock work and so
each of them in different layers also
have slightly different colors to give
the illusion that their rock pieces
instead of just
cylinders and then he's putting many of
them together
in a kind of rock formation to make it
look like a big thunder mountain style
rock section which is one of my favorite
things ever in this game it's really
cool
i highly recommend watching watching
that video because it's just
insanely inspiring to to see him do that
kind of stuff
i think it's honestly out of the uh
at least out of my skill sets within the
scenario play throughs to do anything
like that
not to mention it's very time consuming
but it's it's that kind of
you know using pieces in completely
different contexts and trying to come up
with your own
uses for any pieces that's one of my
favorite parts of parkitect
and it really just works because of the
very minimalistic
gameplay style sorry that was a bit of a
tangent i was just reminded of it
because i built this tower with
basic structure pieces as well kind of
like he did his rock work
and then funnily enough this tower also
uses rock work
as regular building pieces and columns
whereas
you know in reality they are meant for
rocks so
the overall message i would say is take
any supposed destination for a piece and
park tank with a grain of salt because
you can use them for
anything you want if you have enough
imagination
anyway we move into the final section of
this scenario which is me
at last adding uh food and drink stars
it's a bit of uh of a problem i suppose
because i'm only adding this
once i have all of the coasters in and
usually
i would suggest you build the food
stalls and drink stalls and
especially toilets before you build
anything else but in this case
i was just too inspired to build the
coasters and i figured you know
for the time being the guests can wait
hold up their pee
uh get hungry and thirsty enough until
they start purchasing all of my products
at
horrible prices so you know i i i didn't
play it the right way in this scenario
but
it's just that i wanted to start with
the coasters and then see
how i could fit in some stalls and
things like that later on
so eventually the the plan became to
build this kind of
main temple structure bizarre kind of
structure here at the top of the
scenario right at the entrance
i'm honestly still not entirely sure
what kind of theme this is
trying to be it's very much inspired by
south american temples but at the same
time taking it so much
further and you know becoming very
fantasy like
but this overall cluster of buildings
is a little bit like temple grounds
castle-esque
i don't know i just thought it looked
cool and that's why i ended up going for
it
and especially with the context of this
eurofighter coaster here
it allowed for me to have lots of space
for different block break sections
and also a break run at the end of the
ride so you can really incorporate
it into the building structures which
works nicely for the scenery
and it gives the coaster some really
cool interaction
but it also helps me to actually have a
purpose for all of these buildings
which you know looks nice but also
motivates me to actually finish these
things
and so this is the final tower here
we just have some kind of miniature
versions of what the big tower is all
the way on the left
just to try and you know stick to a
singular theme one thing that i noticed
while i was building was that i was
really gravitating to almost a kind of
art deco
inspired fantasy style so you can really
see the uh
kind of chrysler building empire state
building references on the the big tower
here
which honestly now that i think about it
makes a little bit more sense than i was
thinking because art deco
is definitely a style that at times has
been inspired by
native american architectural styles so
it's kind of funny how that works out
but yeah that's basically it for this
scenario
so let's take a quick look at the
finished map and see how it turned out
alright so here we go we're basically
done with this scenario
we've almost reached the goal and it's
time to uh
do an overview of the park uh see how
everything turned out
and see what the rides are like and this
time i also want to zoom in on
the statistics of these things so um
let's quickly take a look at this one 83
that's a pretty good excitement rating
who am i kidding that's extreme that's
really good uh
good enough for uh the 65 that we need
anyway
so this is the wing coaster the first
coaster of the scenario
i think it only makes sense to try and
do these in a chronological order
so we start off kind of thunderbird
esque with that launch
into a large kind of sidewinder thing i
mean it's technically a corkscrew there
and then into this kind of meandering
curve elements
a little bit overbanked into a zero g
roll into a helix
and then a crazy element all the way at
the bottom of this lake
where we go into a kind of cobra raw
it's funny because on the last episode i
had lots of comments
about the dog tongue on max force which
was an element most similar to what i
was building on the steel coaster
in timber creek and lots of you guys
were commenting that that's probably
what i could have named that element
even if it was a little bit different
and i feel like this once again is an
element that's kind of a little bit like
it
uh in a sense that it arrives from a
different direction
than it uh leaves the element out of but
then again this isn't quite the same as
on max force because it does have
proper fully formed corkscrews here so
this is
uh still a unique kind of cobra roll i
suppose
anyway that's it for uh for the goals of
this scenario let's take a look
at not whoever arlene walker is but at
the stats for the constrictor
which is a kind of shifting as we're
looking at it
that's what happens after every ride in
the game
but 82 83 isn't too bad of a score
either
that's uh still way better than i ever
needed for this scenario
so here we see we have a kind of oh
that's awesome interaction
i love it here we have a kind of
daymonen from tivoli ask start
with some meandering turns into a
vertical loop and then we have an
overbank turn kind of strange zigzag
element back down into this sidewinder
and after we pass underneath the lift
hill here a kind of
interlocking corkscrew action into the
crazy mess of scenery we have in here
some quick pops of air time and then
finally another cobra roll
i realized that somehow i managed to get
three cobra rolls kind of interlocking
each other at the bottom of this lake
here so that's a very
interesting setup for sure it's kind of
going through some trees there but
you know nobody saw that happen so
that's that
but there's something i have to point
out about this coaster that i only just
now realized
and if you've been paying attention
during the time lapses you've probably
been face bombing the entire time
because well i made a bit of an oopsie
on this coaster if i turn off the
scenery for one you can see
the absolute tangle of coaster stations
track work
and path sections that are hidden
beneath
this crazy massive scenery but i also
realized that
somehow i was brain farting all over the
place and i built
two queue lines for this coaster so
the way this coaster now works is it has
an exit
on this station which is how it's
supposed to be because this is supposed
to be the unload station but it also has
a queue line
um i really don't know why i built a
queue line here like
i was trying to pay attention but
apparently i messed it up big time
but we have a q line here and a q line
here for the same coaster
and it's not too noticeable once all the
scenery is in place so i never
thought anything was wrong but once you
turn off the scenery
uh you start to notice yeah something's
not right here
but the funny part is this actually
works and
this taught me something new about park
tech that i never knew before
you can have multiple load stations so
people can get in on this queue
and they're gonna take this little curve
into the other station and then
whoever's waiting
on this station they're just going to
join the people who are already in the
train
so here you see nobody's getting out
there's no exit but the right
works perfectly fine the new people just
enter the train
and once it's filled completely the
train goes on its merry way into the
layout
so yeah for a second when i discovered
that i had two queue lines for this
coaster i was really afraid that it was
messing up the way that this thing was
working somehow but instead
it's kind of cool actually it has two
loading stations
now of course this is not my intention
it's not a realistic thing at all
but it's good to know and it's maybe
something that would be fun to
experiment with
at some point in the future because i
really wasn't expecting this to actually
work out
so kudos to the the park tech team for
somehow making this thing work
that shouldn't even work in the first
place
anyway that's it for uh our friends the
floorless coaster
and the uh wing coaster let's take a
look at the flying coaster
which i have no idea where the trains
are at all right so one train is on the
second lift hill let's see where the
other train is
and also a quick overview of the stats
this one doesn't have
the very best stats in the park somehow
i'm actually a little bit surprised by
how low these stats are
but it's still well broadly good enough
to make this scenario anyway
so who cares so here we drop down past
the hillside
into this light to fly half loop and
then we get a kind of
crazy hillside helix element here where
it does a
light to fly here and this honestly
seems like a really cool element for a
flying coaster and then we dip down into
crazy long drop
hit our top speed even 90 kilometers an
hour which is
pretty speedy for this kind of coaster
and into the cobro
which as you can tell is a very unique
element for a flying coaster i imagine
you're really whipped into your harness
at the bottom of those drops but at the
same time
i kind of feel like it could work out
but then again
i'm not sure especially because on these
flying coasters you usually
don't want to get too strong positive
g-forces
when you're um you're facing the
direction of the ground because then you
get pushed into your harness quite
brutally
but then again it feels
plausible enough for me to to leave it
in the layout and then we go into the
pretzel loop which is another one of
those
brutal elements for the flying coaster
really one of my favorite elements
on a coaster in general and finally
one more barrel roll and a quick turn
around this forest here
and we're back into the station but yeah
the one thing that i kind of miss on
this flying coaster is maybe
the kind of role that flying dinosaur
or starry sky ripper both in japan and
china respectively have
which is that kind of thing where you do
a full rotation and then another half
rotation
those are really some of the coolest
elements that the flying coaster can
give but
it's really difficult to work it into a
layout especially in parking but that
aside
this is a kind of my dream flying
coaster
especially with how terrain conforming
it is it's almost like air in autumn
towers was
actually extreme anyway let's quickly
pause because i see a eurofighter is
reaching the top
of this hill here so yeah here we have
the kind of
art deco temple tower with the vertical
lift hill
and honestly i think this is the first
time i've themed up a eurofighter lift
hill this way in park text
and i think i want to do it more it's
really fun to do and it looks pretty
cool
uh this ride is also way too cheap let's
make that 12
come on you guys have been getting a
bargain um
but yeah let's let's give it a spin see
how it goes
so here we drop down into that vertical
drop very smooth gradual transition into
the vertical loop
where you really get some nice hang time
at the top possibly
some really cool interaction with the
flying coaster as well but we just
barely missed that
and here we have the large turnaround
elements just a giant helix
into this kind of i guess
a little bit airtimey curve and then we
go into the barrel roll and into the
final break run where we
do a quick tour of this building site
kind of thingamajig i'm still not sure
how to call this thing but i'm pretty
happy with how it turned out
especially given the fact that it houses
a bunch of important stuff
some queues some exits some toilets and
of course food stalls as well
so really one of the most important
functionality-wise buildings of the park
and there you have it that's jungle
adventures
with kind of three distinct segments
almost we have the crazy
compact messy buildings of this lower
section here with
lots of interaction between the coasters
and the pathworks and the scenery
the flying coaster which is kind of
doing its own thing over here but really
packed into the the dense forest in this
area
and finally the the temple grounds with
the big tower
and really the weenie of this episode
so with that all said i'm very curious
to see what'll be the uh
the trophy we get for this scenario i
suspect it's probably gonna be this
thing but it could also be
this little tower i guess we'll see
let's quit
and see what happens
so all right
oh it's actually that tower fair enough
so that's that now let's get to the
review of the next park
i'm honestly not sure which one this is
so it's gonna be a surprise for me as
well
uh okay now i know it yeah that's
technopolis
all right that's gonna be uh that's
gonna be it for this episode
i hope you guys enjoyed and i'll see you
in the next one
bye